Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is my happy episode. Why is that? Well, of
course, because today we are talking about light
transport simulations, and in particular, Intel’s
amazing new technique, that can take this, and
make it into…this! Wow. It can also take this, and
make it into…this. My goodness, this is amazing.
But wait a second, what is going on here?
What are these noisy videos for, and why?
Well, if we wish to create a truly gorgeous
photorealistic scene, in computer graphics,
we usually reach out to a light transport
simulation algorithm, and then, this happens.
Oh no! We have noise. Tons of it. But why? Well,
during the simulation, we have to shoot millions
and millions of light rays into the scene to
estimate how much light is bouncing around,
and before we have simulated enough rays, the
inaccuracies in our estimations show up as noise
in these images. This clears up over time, but it
may take a long time. How do we know that? Well,
have a look at the reference simulation footage
for this paper. See? There is still some noise in
here. I am sure this should clean up over time,
but no one said that it would do so quickly. A
video like this might require hours to days
to compute. For instance, this is from our
previous paper that took 3 weeks to finish and
it ran on multiple computers at the same time.
So, is all hope lost for these beautiful
photorealistic simulations? Well,
not quite! Instead of waiting for hours or
days, what if I told you that we can just
wait for a small fraction of a second, about 10
milliseconds. It will produce this. And then,
run a previous noise filtering technique
that is specifically tailored for light
transport simulations, and what
do we get? Probably not much,
right? I can barely tell what I should be seeing
here. So, let’s see a previous method. Whoa! That
is way better. I was barely able to guess what
these are, but now we know: gratings. Great!
So, we don’t have to wait for hours
to days for a simulated world to
come alive in a video like this, just a few
milliseconds. At least for the simulation,
we don’t know how long the noise filtering takes.
And now, hold on to your papers, because this
was not today’s paper’s result. I hope this one
can do even better. And, look, instead, it can do
this. Wow. This is so much better! And the result
of the reference simulation for comparison,
this is the one that takes forever to compute.
Let’s also have a look at the videos and compare
them. This is the noisy input simulation, wow,
this is going to be hard. Now, the previous
method. Yes, this is clearly better, but there
is a problem. Do you see the problem? Oh yes,
it smoothed out the noise, but it smoothed the
details too. Hence, a lot of them are lost. So,
let’s see what Intel’s new method can do instead.
Now we’re talking! So much better. I
absolutely love it. It is still not as
sharp as the reference simulation, however,
in some regions, depending on your taste,
it might even be more pleasing
to the eye than this reference.
And it gets better! This technique does not only
denoising, but upsampling too. This means that
it is able to create a higher resolution image
with more pixels than the input footage. Now,
get ready, one more comparison and I’ll
tell you how long the noise filtering took.
Whoa, I wonder what it will do with this noisy
mess. I have no idea what is going on here.
And neither does this previous technique.
And this is not some ancient technique,
this previous method is the Neural Bilateral
Grid, a learning-based method from just two
years ago. And now, have a look at this.
My goodness! Is this really possible? So
much progress just one more paper down
the line! I absolutely love it. So good!
So, how long do we have to wait for an
image like this? Still hours to days? Well,
not at all. This all runs not only in real
time, it runs faster than real time! Yes,
that means about 200 frames per second for
the new noise filtering step. And remember,
the light simulation part typically takes 4-12
milliseconds on these scenes, this is the noisy
mess that we get. And just 5 milliseconds later,
we get this. I cannot believe it. Bravo! So,
real-time light transport simulations
from now on? Oh yes, sign me up right
now! What a time to be alive! So, what do
you think? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!